so so whatever happened to man in the
past 10 years people on the III don't
know what it is but I kind of feel like
social media has acted as a sort of
filter that's moved people into two
camps left and right yeah and what I
think happened is it's not that the left
and the right are actually politically
left or politically right mm-hmm
certainly a lot of people who used to be
left now claim to be conservative even
though they're not ah it's more so about
free thinking Liberty minded individuals
and it just so happens that many
conservatives now align with like you
know liberals it's like I was saying you
like ben shapiro and dave rubin
fundamentally disagreeing like bench
berm won't even come to his you know
right wedding anniversary or whatever
but they're not yelling at each other
but they're friends right and they
disagree on like core life issues
because that's what America used to kind
of be right I say kind of be because
they're still crazy people sure but now
you've basically the left as I see it is
a chaotic a destructive force with no
goal other than it's just fire pure fire
yeah it's like they're they've kind of
lost track of what they were going for
but they're like well we've gone too far
we got to just keep going no no it's the
remnants all right so like same thing
basically so I've been I grew up in
Chicago lived in New York always been
pretty left like that you you were yeah
you were you big into Bernie Sanders
back in 2016
yeah yeah I like Bernie and we do 2016
you say your friends were half of them
yeah I have a lot of Trump supporting
friends too yeah yeah because well you
were in Arizona too so yeah a lot of
conservative I mean yeah I mean I
doesn't matter what kind of thing you
support exactly I'm not gonna like cut
you out of my life but you're like humph
but I'm working like Hillary it doesn't
matter like as long as you you're still
a good person then we can be friends so
what ends up happening is you have
regular people not super into politics
yeah and then you're faced with this
current phenomenon where you've got some
people who are like I may disagree but
I'll sit down with you right and other
people who are alike rare is screeching
yeah I'm not friends with the repo right
creatures and that's the left has become
yeah
I don't get it like I mean so I'm not
gonna throw any direct [ __ ] I'm not
gonna call specific people out right now
but there are some independent
commentators okay that produce on social
media and we did we did briefly talk
about this the other day and it's like
they're their only argument is insults
and derision okay so it's like if Donald
Trump does something they'll say like
what and what a [ __ ] idiot things like
that do you have the Donald Trump reply
guys right you know those guys yeah yeah
so Donald Trump tweets Fame seekers
basically no they're just there they're
just it's perhaps it's Trump derangement
syndrome I think it's a combo yeah I
mean most they get traffic I think you
know it comes down to is the left is
primarily emotionally unstable people
and the right I'm doing air quotes
because I don't mean politically
laughter politically right I'm saying
like the culture war factions yeah the
right is comprised of people who are
much more emotionally stable the reason
I say that is because if you and it's
not Universal it's not absolute but you
look at like the intellectual dark web
types yeah
they tend to be leftist right so your
firm every intellectual dark web Jordan
Peterson right so I don't know what it
was what does Jordy he's like a moderate
right
it's like fairly moderate no I guess so
okay but you look at the Weinstein
brothers you look at people like Joe
Rogan and you have very progressive
individuals okay but they're emotionally
stable they can have an argument they
can sit down yeah and you end up with
this large faction of politically
homeless I think I think it's a Brigitte
fantasy calls it that I don't know if
she coined that phrase but the
politically homeless are people who are
pretty much leftists like liberal
left-leaning individuals but are
emotionally stable yeah so they find
themselves more in alignment with the
right I'm sure there'll be a lot of
people are left who will like point to a
bunch of idiot right wingers and be like
Tim's wrong but the point is I'm not
talking about political there's idiots
everywhere right and you can you know
whatever but when the highest profile
individuals at the left are just totally
lying you know I mean it's fair to point
out there are some conservatives who
pump out ridiculous nonsense to of
course there are mm-hmm but I you know
when I look to what the left has done
politically it's like conservatives and
Trump supporters are making an argument
for
what Trump has done and you get
intellectual dark web types like Eric
Weinstein saying I completely disagree
with this and Trump is not viable and
here he is sitting down talking about it
you're like here here like thank you for
expressing your opinion yeah but you
don't get that on whatever the other
culture war faction is you get things
like you should be banned your show
should be like removed you get canceled
culture stuff it's the closer it's it's
really amazing there was a there's a
woman I know and she tweeted the other
day the New York Times article that said
you know we think Joe Biden did it we're
gonna own it and vote for him anyway
yeah and she tweeted something like my
sentiment as a sentiment as well I'm
gonna I'm gonna vote for Biden even
though I believe this woman and she
ended up getting ratio super heart right
and her response was I'm being attacked
by BOTS trolls no BOTS oh really no she
said I'm being attacked by BOTS Oh she
was as well she was on that she was
being targeted Bernie BOTS and GOP
people or whatever and then she
suggested that Twitter revoke api's API
keys in reference to like automation
yeah it's like that's what they think
they're there in this world where they
can't fathom that they actually just are
getting heat from people for saying
something dumb none of these people are
real it must be BOTS right they're
disagreeing with me yep yep and they're
about not surprising they're about yeah
yeah definitely exist but this sentiment
has been going on for years like if you
look you know you know it's interesting
I think this is a really easy way to
explain like a bit of evidence as to my
perspective on this of course I'm sure
there's me a bunch of lefty commentators
we're gonna like here this would be like
Tim's insane if you think that sure it
was like fine you believed you want boom
tie something Alex Jones got purged
might be platformer Rachel Maddow got
dropped gone and her ratings are
skyrocketing I mean I mean it writes it
down down to crazy no I'd never watched
him before starting the show but I I've
gathered some information seen some
stuff and he's kind of kooky but he's
he's the funny actually he's at the same
time it's like but it's but listen who
cares we can play a game of who said it
Rachel Maddow or Alex Jones yeah one
said that Jeffrey Epstein is running a
kitty trafficking island and he needs to
be stopped
another said Russia is going to shut off
the
electricity to your home potentially in
the winter in Fargo think about what
that means who said it no I have known
Rachel Maddow said that one and that's
the famous like insanity conspiracy line
that Russia's gonna shut down Fargo's
electricity yep she's nuts she's nuts
she did a segment where she was like but
she's on the Left Russia yes and so when
she went insane propping up the most
psychotic Donald dude MSNBC had a guy on
arguing that Trump may very well be a
Russian asset since the 1980s oh my
goodness what psychotic parallel
universe these people live in but what
happens with MSNBC is they get pushed
forward dropped up if you go if you
listen to Fox News what do they tell you
well they'll tell you some conservative
buying on a large box they'll tell you
conservative buy stuff but they'll tell
you the Russia conspiracy stuff is
insane and if it was how aren't we
finding out like the Russian stuff is
all made up anyway yep it's like it's
all a bunch of well Russia was trying to
you know meddle but they spent like
thousands of dollars and influenced
hundreds of people like it's a
ridiculously minor that's it and the
effect I believe give thousands not
hundreds of thousands tens of thousands
just thousands I'm pretty sure it's
thousands or like yeah we spent like
eight thousand bucks just to see if we
can make a difference well no it's like
tens of thousands hundred thousand okay
but in terms of direct spend on like
social media was nothing and so I think
the official assessment is that they had
zero impact yeah but what they like to
say is that you know Senate committee
has found that Russia was trying to prop
up Donald Trump and then they come out
in March he the Russia is trying to prop
up Bernie Sanders it's fake
it's like it's it's it's it's insanity
man so we think about what ends up
happening you get Rachel Maddow spouting
ridiculous conspiracy garbled trash yeah
hey okay so what happens to these people
who hear this all day they live in this
parallel paranoid delusional state yes
and they have Trump derangement syndrome
where even after it's been proven now
multiple times that Trump didn't collude
with Russia they still believe it you
know even as even like in January Pelosi
is like it's Trump bargain with Putin
they're just nuts so I think I think it
comes down to like these social media
companies and these media outlets are
biased towards the left just because
been the default for them okay and so
they have Trump has to be wrong no
matter what but if Trump is always wrong
that means when Trump is right you were
wrong that's good so these so these
people end up watching the stuff
believing insane conspiracy stuff and
then you end up with moderates and
conservatives standing next to each
other scratching their heads while the
people on the left are smashing windows
starting fires and screeching that
Russia has taken over and then when it's
not Russia it's Ukraine and it was not
Ukraine it's China and it's like at a
certain point you think they were gonna
realize like this so here's my ultimate
point why I say that the left is
emotionally unstable and the right and I
don't mean necessarily the political I
mean like the factions of the culture
work it's because after the Russia gate
failed in hundred years after Ukraine
gate failed after several months and
then they tried doing the China thing
which lasted a week you'd think at a
certain point that they would learn you
know what's the definition of insanity
that they like to say doing the same
thing over and over again expecting
expecting a different result you know
it's not really the definition of
insanity it's just like some buzz phrase
you hear on the internet all they're
doing is just making themselves seem
like fools to the general public so the
general public who thought they were
Democrats are like am i Democrat do I
actually align with this left lefty
thing that's happening cuz I I thought I
was a lefty for a long time but you are
I guess I would think that I am but like
hearing us talk about like over the past
couple months like about what they do
what how they screech and how they do
things it's like I don't know if I
associate with that kind of person
exactly yeah and so if there is no
establishment and I don't mean like the
elite establishment if there is no
actual left right that you can
communicate with you'll never hear any
arguments for their ideas you have the
craziest thing I saw was mhm Jacobin
magazine socialist magazine okay
Jacobin is a reference to the the French
Revolution the jacobins okay socialists
wrote an article that the Democrats and
the media were actually the ones
colluding with Russia by pushing Russian
propaganda and I'm sitting here thinking
like wow when the Socialists agree with
the Trump supporters whatever the left
is in this country is like a it's like
the pile of it's like
little bits of cran mashed into a into a
ball and then like warmed up so it
clusters together that's like no real
it's just a massive random slime you
know forming in the in the corner so
it's like since you know I think
happened I think the left was kind of
playing the game with the Democrats like
I mean leftists like far left of
socialists yeah because they wanted
Bernie to win and they want to take over
once they got out stood they have no
allegiance to the Democrats so now
they're like yep these people are nuts
that makes sense yeah man I feel bad for
the people who watch Maddow
it's like and and and for and to the
same extent I feel bad for the people
who get entrenched in YouTube conspiracy
stuff Alex Jones or otherwise Aaron's
watching Maddow didn't angry all stuff
absolutely serious go on they go on
Facebook and they're like maybe orange
man yeah it's like yeah you know listen
if you really think Joe Biden can win
like you're not stable you know like uh
who are these people
yeah you know you know what man you mean
you take a look at those polls showing
that the the voters about Cavanaugh
seventy percent said Kevin I shouldn't
be right you know but Biden no they
flip-flop these people these
high-profile individuals on Twitter who
represent the resistance it's like
they're they're NPCs like that's really
the best way to explain it you know they
they have no real opinions they have no
principles no morals they're just it's
like they're not I'm not calling them
BOTS in the sense that like they're fake
people yeah but they have no thoughts of
their own it's you can predict like I'd
be willing to bet you could look at one
of these resistance people yeah and you
could actually map out what their tweets
will be over the next month you're like
exactly what they're gonna say you could
probably like a story breaks right and
it'll be like you know Donald Trump
sells you know weapons Saudi Arabia and
you can write the tweet before they do
and then tag them in it and then like
wait for them to tweet it because that's
how predictable and in saying these
people are ya know gonna be wrong
they're conservative to do the same
thing and that's like you know they're
trying to rally a base but I think there
are a few people I know who are on the
Left we have built careers as like left
wing commentators I feel like they're
lying I watch them tweet stuff and I'm
like you really don't believe
you know but you have no choice because
your base is just these people do you
know them personally though oh yeah so
you can tell you know that oh they're
real personality yep it's not so much
about their personality I know some
people who know their core I don't
they'll help they'll put out two
complete BS you know and then I'm like
you know that's BS right and logo huh
they won't change huh okay yeah huh Wow
yep and it's because if they say it
they'll lose subscribers they'll lose
money yeah I don't care your audience
agrees there's no principals there yeah
it's like the goal is to just get
traffic make money and it's funny that
they accused me of the same thing and
it's like man I'd love nothing more than
just like living the van down by the
river you know I mean you're
skateboarding every day and I have to
have people worried about this I'm
talking about whatever whatever I want
but when you combine that when you I
think I think that's actually what's
holding but whatever the left is that we
call the colloquial left whatever
whatever it is is being held together by
these people who are pretending so long
as you have high-profile individuals on
Twitter who want followers you know they
will say the most shocking and mom
bastok thing possible to maintain their
status and stature and they don't care
you know about any of this stuff that
you know what I've talked about this
before too but you know for those that
haven't heard it I'll tell you exactly
how it happens so early on and this is
this is like a semi real world example
somebody writes an article that says
Donald Trump you know makes a comment
and it's called racist it's an article
they write it they publish it it's a
million views okay
so then their boss is like oh you got a
million views on that one see what else
you can find the next day they write
Donald Trump makes another racist
comment gets another million views the
next day they write Donald Trump is
racist
another million views the next day they
write Donald Trump is the worst racist
Donald Trump is the most racist we've
ever seen Donald Trump is the is it you
know is running for president and he
will be a white supremacist president
and then finally Trump is almost as bad
as Hitler Trump is literally Hitler
Trump is worse than Hitler and the
reason is every day they have to one-up
what they said yesterday yeah because if
they just write the same article over
and over
again you know click drug yep yeah
people get a like they adapt words and
they slowly start you know they build up
a tolerance so I mean that's just really
what what's happening it happens to a
lot of people and if if people aren't
willing to accept that they're
advocating for a broken system
a failed politician Joe Biden not gonna
work unless they want the chaos vote
like you said yesterday yeah but I don't
think so I think wanted watch the world
burn right I think anybody was actually
paying attention you know has either
left the left because we like how come
there's no walk away from the Republican
Party campaign that's true you know the
walk away campaign yeah of course
where's the where's the Republican one
where's the walk away from Trump it's
almost it's interesting it's like people
who like Trump still love Trump and they
love him more every day probably even
people who don't like Trump are going to
Trump you said you were gonna vote for
Trump yeah but you're not a mugger
hat-wearing you're a skateboarding vegan
hippie bro it's true I will not vote for
Biden Joe Joe Rogan said it now you made
a good point yesterday he he upped the
economy like Obama's like you can't do
it and then he did it he and he brought
the numbers up crazy so the economy did
really well under his administration so
this now where we have this pandemic so
we're gonna trust some random person we
don't know I mean if the Democrats do
choose someone new that we don't even
know who it is it's like I highly
suspect that's gonna happen it's like
wah Moe I don't know what Cuomo's I
don't know anything about this dude you
know as far as what he does
business-wise I mean Trump has shown
that he can bolster our economy the best
economy we had a generation we need that
especially now that has been shut down
for so long
yup yeah yeah yeah bingo yeah right
there exactly there's there's almost so
in terms of talking about like who you
would vote for you've got foreign policy
issues health care issues you know but
for most Americans it's the economy all
right that's the saying it's the economy
stupid you know well Donald Trump's
proven that he made an amazing economy
for three years now that they kind of so
this is actually in the polling that I
was just reading earlier today Americans
don't blame Trump for the pandemic in
the economic crisis okay and if that's
the case
they assume he's the best choice to fix
it because of what he did in the first
three years of his first term yeah and
there's been so much like so many
different articles that I've seen where
they're trying to blame him every chance
they get they want to hell they want to
pin this on Trump and it's like how
endlessly how can they do that it
doesn't make any sense I've read the
articles some people send them my way
and I'm just like reading it I'm like
this doesn't even make any sense
so here's what happens if Trump is wrong
you know every so often certain issues
yeah then the media is inverted and that
means they're wrong on most issues right
if Trump was right about economics and
he was like let's say he was right a
person at the time that means the
Democrats the media were wrong 8% of the
time and that's kind of what's happening
yeah so but yet to go back to my other
the point I was making about like you
saying you do it for Trump Brogan's
saying he'd rather vote for Trump you
know there's there's very there been
people who have left the Republican
Party like Justin Amash for instance but
there's and the never Trump errs for
sure because he was gonna lose his spot
was he leaving or was he just kind of a
Hail Mary to keep some spotlight I don't
I think he made a bad bet yeah I think
what he saw cuz he was a Republican he
saw like people don't like Trump women
don't like Trump so he was scratching
his beard going like he's never bared
I'm kidding but you know he's thinking
like how do i win reelection I gotta
leave the Republican Party it did well
for him and a bunch of followers got you
know high-profile push but that means
when it comes time to actually run in
his district district again he's he yeah
the whole Republican base yeah so now
people are gonna walk in they're gonna
go are they're not gonna they're not
gonna rally for independent so now he's
trying to go elect Libertines or
whatever so there have been some
instance of people leaving the
Republican Party for sure they're on
Twitter you can see them
Trump gret they call it but the movement
the high profile walk away you hear so
much more often absolutely yeah you're
right it's because even the people who
don't want to vote for Trump like I
mentioned the intellectual dark web
people mm-hmm they're not voting for
Biden they're not gonna pretend they
vote for Biden and even the progressives
we're not gonna vote for Biden so what
is it yeah and who are they who are
these
where's these poll proving that Biden's
ahead of Trump it's like all just
sitting in a room like well what do you
think yeah yep I didn't everyone Biden
all right yep well I guess he's ahead of
them polls thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you